[Music]
foreign
we're going to begin with breaking news
out of Beijing where the Chinese foreign
Ministry says it regrets what called a
civilian balloon straying into U.S
airspace Beijing says it's a civilian
object meant for scientific research the
Pentagon had early called it a spy
balloon and was tracking the balloon
flying over the state of Montana
Kimberly Hawk is joining us live now
from the White House this has had the
U.S in under great attention over the
last couple of days what is going to
happen now what more do we know
oh well according to the Pentagon what
we know is that the U.S government has
been tracking this very carefully what
we understand is that this is a high
altitude surveillance balloon uh it was
first spotted over the U.S state of
Montana this is uh close to the Canadian
border it was spotted by people on the
ground who were wondering what was in
the sky that is how the U.S government
first learned about this incredibly and
it was then that the U.S government
started tracking it now there are going
to have to be some answers as to why it
was bystanders that first spotted this
and not the military or the US
government having said all of that the
US government now watching it very
closely assuring the public that this is
not in any way in commercial airspace in
other words meaning that it's not going
to come in contact with any passenger
Chets or any sort of commercial air
traffic it's much higher now what is it
doing it's intelligence gathering and
the concern is is that it is flying over
some very sensitive areas particularly
what we know to be three nuclear missile
silo Fields now according to the
Pentagon as soon as the U.S government
was aware that this was taking place in
terms of the intelligence gathering that
the sensitive data was protected so that
the foreign State actor in this case
China was not able to collect any of the
sensitive data
the timing of this of course is
inconvenient perhaps more so for the us
because of the Secretary of State
Anthony blinken is expected to be
heading to Beijing in a few days for
talk with talks for with President uh
she even if this is just a weather
balloon this puts a lot of the leverage
if you like on China's side doesn't it
it has unsettled the us over the last
couple of days
the tensions between the U.S and China
have been escalating for some time not
just during the tenure of the U.S
President Joe Biden but they've been
ratcheting up under the presidency of
Donald Trump there were sanctions that
were put in place or rather tariffs that
were put in place very strict trade
tariffs and as well there have been a
very tense words that have been put in
place and we should point out when it
comes to those trade tariffs those were
not dropped on the part of Joe Biden and
so uh there have been a very tense
exchanges that have taken place well
we've heard Joe Biden talking about his
strong relationship with the Chinese
government we also know that there has
been backdoor Espionage that the US is
Accused the Chinese government of being
responsible for for decades and so this
is sort of an ongoing concern of the
United States that this is just in the
case of this balloon well it is kind of
a low-tech version the of intelligence
gathering most of the means of
intelligence gathering tends to be more
in the form of satellite as well as
other forms of high-tech intelligence
gathering still this is one of the
concerns of the United States government
is that there is this ongoing collection
that is taking place on the part of
China and that's why there continues to
be this hyper vigilance on the part of
the United States government to continue
to not only monitor this but to try and
divert it
Kimberly thank you very much indeed
that's Kimberly Hawker bringing us up to
date from the White House
let's go to Katrina you she's joining us
on the on Skype from Beijing so this is
a statement that's been made by the
Chinese government earlier on a few
hours ago they were being pretty
cautious and they were saying no let's
just wait and see what unfolds and now
they've as I say issued this statement
what is the what is it that's going on
there at the moment what are they saying
briefing at the foreign Ministry at that
point they did not confirm or deny that
this was a Chinese ship that this was a
surveillance aircraft but now we do have
a statement from Beijing saying that it
is indeed a Chinese vessel but they are
saying that it is not military that it
is not surveillance but in fact it's
what they've called a civilian Airship
which is designed for civilian research
purposes essentially to collect weather
information now they said that this uh
aircraft has limited self steering
capacity and due to a strong Westerly
wind it blew
unintentionally over U.S territory and
this was definitely not planned or not
the intention and this just occurred
according to China due to this Force may
earn this was not
um
planned or any sort of strategic uh move
on beijing's part at least that's what
they're saying they said it deviated far
from course and and Beijing is sending
out a remorseful message saying that
they regret that this has happened it
seems to be highly embarrassing for
China if this is the case and that
they're working with the U.S side to
manage this situation and I think
they're scrambling they're hoping that
this doesn't get out of hand and that's
important as we were talking to Kimberly
just a moment ago about the fact that
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
is heading to Beijing and there was a
point during the last couple of days
when this started to emerge that as
people started to think those meetings
were not going to be easy at all but if
China is responding as you're suggesting
then perhaps this is an effort to try
and get things back on track ahead of
that meeting
thank you
that's right I think this is coming also
at a time where we've seen from China
less of a strident aggressive tone and
when it comes to uh communicating with
the US and more of a conciliatory tone
this has certainly been the case for the
last few weeks especially leading up to
this meeting the U.S side itself has
said that the whole point of blinken's
visit to China the highest ranking
official to visit China since the
beginning of the pandemic was to set
guard rails to avoid any major points of
dispute spiraling out of control and and
escalating into some uncontrollable uh
conflict or becoming something that
can't be controlled by either government
and so China has been quite Coy it
hasn't confirmed this meeting officially
but it has said uh that they're working
with the U.S side and certainly for
China they are wanting to reach out and
work not only with the us but also other
U.S allies we've had China's uh
diplomats working with for example
Australia having me meetings there China
at the moment has just reopened from
covid its economy is slowing it's really
Keen to you know welcome foreign
investment and put on a more friendly
face but at the same time we've got
these meetings coming and Anthony
blinken should he come to China and have
these meetings there is a long list of
disputes any everything ranging from uh
potential clashes over the South China
Sea the status of Taiwan Tech controls
from the U.S imposed on China and
Chinese companies already we have a very
tense list of talking points and no
doubt this aircraft be it a surveillance
ship or a weather balloon essentially
this is only going to add and complicate
those matters when the two sides sit
down if they do sit down and continue
those meetings on Sunday Katrina you and
Beijing thank you
the European unions